of all the many terrifying fey-like
monsters haunting the Waters of the
world the Nixie stands out these
half-human half fish beans May at first
glance look familiar but they are much
older and much scarier than the usual
mermaid of Pop Culture thanks Ariel they
love to shape-shift and sing mesmerizing
Melodies all while harboring an
insatiable desire for humans which often
veers into a dark obsession
so what is a Nixie a water Sprite a
nymph a mermaid technically yeah
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
the Nixie belongs to a large Germanic
tradition of murderous shape-shifting
water nymphs that also appear in
folklore from Switzerland and
Scandinavia known throughout folklore by
many names these deadly and enchanting
water creatures may take the appearance
of an old human with green teeth green
skin and green hair most of the time
though they take the form of a beautiful
human covered with moss and seaweed and
decorated with shells some German
Legends describe the Nixie with slit
ears or fishtails when they are in the
water they have the ability to appear
clothed on land but the water dripping
from their garments gives away their
true identity throwing stones into the
water can irritate the Nixie who may
create a storm in response yup these
water monsters control the weather an
additionally scary thing about the Nixie
is that they can haunt any body of water
no well-stream River Pond lake or ocean
is safe they lure their victims with
music usually singing or in some stories
they imitate a crying child to draw
someone near before seizing and pulling
their prey below the surface what they
do with them from their verys in many
tales the Nixie serve as a cautionary
tale for children who are told to avoid
the water so as not to be grabbed
implying that they will not return in
Other Stories the monsters require an
annual human sacrifice and they prefer
children stories of the deadly Nixie
usually end with death but there are
also accounts of a more romantic
persuasion
sometimes they will transform into
horses to carry their willing human
lovers to their Crystal palaces some of
these monsters apparently have alluring
underwater homes so yes these stories
imply that the Nixie mate with humans
though such romantic encounters are not
encouraged in their society said to be
ruled by a malevolent water deity akin
to Satan named Nick from the ancient
Icelandic he will kill any of the Nixie
who dare to even talk to a human
described as more of a classic mermaid
or merman old Nick is the fish-tailed
father of all the nixies over time and
in some regions this water deity became
watered down into the nixies who borrow
his name because of this etymological
connection the Nixie is associated with
malice more often than many of their
Global counterparts before Nick and
therefore all nixies somewhere around
700 CE the famous text Beowulf mentioned
knickers violent water monsters some
folklorists theorize that nixies may
have originated from ancient spiritual
practices of river and water God worship
that turned nefarious after the
introduction of Christian Christianity
when water worship was discouraged still
Whispers and legends of the monster
persisted and became popular across the
globe thanks to a few key books in the
19th century in the German fairy tale
undeen published in 1811 a Nixie here
called water Sprite appears on the
doorstep of a couple whose daughter
drowned earlier that day appearing as a
young human girl dripping wet she is
taken in by The Grieving parents she is
exquisitely beautiful with golden hair
but is also known to have Supernatural
powers like controlling water and the
weather and a fiery temperament
eventually undeen marries a knight and
overnight becomes a nicer more
accommodating person she claims the
change is due to her now possessing a
soul apparently as a water spray she
didn't have one and can only get one by
marrying a human even after she reveals
her true nature including her people's
great Beauty and otherworldly singing
voices her husband seems okay with the
whole thing which granted doesn't seem
all that bad considering her water spray
great uncle however is not pleased with
his inter-being marriage and repeatedly
attacks the couple and their company
with waves frightening apparitions
storms and floods eventually undeen is
forced to return to the nixie's
underwater Crystal Kingdom after her
husband accuses her of being a sorceress
meanwhile her former night husband
remarries his former love and the old
couple's biological daughter who in a
strange twist didn't drown after all due
to the rules of the Nixie Society undeen
must reappear on land and give her
husband a killer kiss for his infidelity
drowning him with her tears so we have a
beautiful kind Nixie who yes is forced
to kill her husband but the tale is
presented as a tragic love story oh and
this story yeah it helped Inspire Hans
Christian Anderson's The Little Mermaid
the Nixie and the brothers Grim 1857
tale Nix the Mill Pond lacks any
redeeming qualities a man who recently
lost his fortune sees a beautiful woman
rise from the Waters of the river by his
Mill he recognizes her as a Nixie
straight off and even though he is
frightened he accepts a strange bargain
from her
she promises to restore his wealth if he
pays her the young thing which has just
been born the young thing turns out to
be his firstborn son whom his wife has
only just delivered when he realizes the
horror of what he has done he raises the
boy to fear the water
this works until his son is now a
married man himself one day after a hunt
without thinking the sun washes his
hands in a pond the Nixie seizes the
opportunity she slowly Rises up from the
water and with a big smile wraps her
arms around him dragging him down into
the water with her his distraught wife
goes to the local witch for help who
advises a series of steps to bring him
out first she Combs her hair near the
water where he was taken it works sort
of her husband's head momentarily
appears above the surface but quickly
disappears under the water again the
next day she plays a flute and this time
half of his body emerges on the third
day she works a golden Spinning Wheel by
the pond and her husband fully emerges
he begins to leave the water but not
before a tidal wave suddenly Rises up
and starts heading towards them the
woman calls upon the witch with one last
plea for help and help she does by
turning the wife into a toad and the
Huntsman into a frog a name them to
survive the torrent of water
luckily they revert back to their human
forms but unluckily they are separated
by The Wave they live separate lives for
years until one day as fate would have
it they cross paths they do not
recognize one another but become good
friends one day the Huntsman plays an
interesting flute song the very same one
his wife did besides the pond so many
years before they suddenly realize who
each other is and fall back in love
these stories established the Nixie as
both villains and victims and
popularized the female Nixie over the
male Knicks nixies along with other
water nymphs and mermaids appear often
in 19th century fiction as folkloric
Femme fatales that reflect patriarchal
society's fear of the increasingly
liberated woman and changing gender
roles because literature emphasizes the
beauty of the Nixie they are often seen
as projections of Desire largely through
the male gaze but others interpret them
as feminist symbols of the power of
women and nature as allegories for death
or even as a reminder of the dangers of
drowning I think more broadly these 19th
century nixies gesture towards modernity
their tempting songs and offers of
treasure akin to the siren pull of
industrialization which likewise
promises luxury and wealth but at a
severe cough according to Folklore the
Nixie lacks maternal Instinct
sensibility and a soul having a fishtail
Supernatural foresight or the ability to
shape-shift are at odds with the parts
of them that are more human-like
but it's The Human Side that presents
the most danger the mouth that can tell
the future or lure one to a watery death
or the arms that pull their prey down
below it's the human qualities that
allow them to slip into society
unnoticed a Wolf Among sheep or rather a
shark among seals
old Nick is the men on my lip I'm sorry
okay that's when it landed on me